Her low freak bitches.
Boom.
They got the things false dam and they opened it.
Yeah,
Hook.
He took a chance with dramatic flare,
a chance and it didn't really pay off.
But if it did well now you have to kill time and shit.
He's got nothing in there.
God.
But he's also the guy that had um,
Dick Gregory actually on his television show debuted is the Zapruder film,
which is the shot of Kennedy's head getting blown off and going back into the
left classic and in what looks like a shot from the front,
it looks like a frontal shot.
It looks like he was actually shot by more than one person if they like.
If you look at,
there's various interpretations of the Zapruder film,
but one interpretation that seems to make a lot of sense.
He said he was hit from both the front end,
the back to show that he was,
there was multiple people shooting at them.
And if you talk to anyone who was trying to,
if you were looked at that pinch point,
like as they make that corner knee in Dealey Plaza,
like they were like,
well you wouldn't just have one guy with a rifle,
you would make sure you were shooting at them from a,
from a bunch of different locations.
And Geraldo dressed probably news and Geraldo showed the video shoulder here.
Hold on a second.
Here's what's important.
That video was many years after Kennedy's assassination.
Yeah,
like a decade.
So for a decade we had all thought that Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone and there
was only a few people that didn't think he did,
but there was no visual evidence that showed differently.
Haley for sure tell us hot chicks Zapruder film is,
it's,
it always baffled me that when you see him get hit,
it looks like for a couple of frames,
it looks like his head,
half his head disappears and there's just a purple blob.
Like it's a purple blob.
But then when you look at the op to autopsy pictures,
it's just a,
the hole in his head,
he just laying there.
But it looks,
it looks like it blew.
It all was tampered with.
That's what it looks.
It doesn't look like the film was tampered with,
but the autopsy photographs were most likely tampered with and this was a big
part of the contention that David Liftin had when he wrote the book best
evidence because there's two different,
let's watch this,
we'll see that it's a perpetual offer.
Two frames.
It's spray the bullets hitting his head,
his heads.
When you hit something with a bullet,
there's a spray.
It looks like his,
his whole face just flies off and they're just,
well they say that his,
his peace and his head flew off and she crawled to on the back to try to put his
head back.
Notion is a human being done?
No,
she didn't.
Well that's what they did not say that.
That's not what happened.
She was trying to get the fuck out of that limousine because people were
shooting and they blew her husband's head off.
She wasn't going for any piece of meat.
That's,
I heard that now she tried.
She was reaching
people say crazy shit like that.
Does not.
She was getting the fuck.
Did she ever talk about power?
We're talking about,
I know she never talked to him for that.
You know she Sakyo Nassis right afterwards.
She married one of the bridges people.
She could fine,
but don't you think with that autopsy they,
they,
it's your president that just got assassinated.
So you're going to want to make him look the best politics.
Look at the video,
the supporter from what does that mean?
Explain,
because this is something that I would really see.
I've read different books on this shit and I've watched 10 or 15 balls
mentoring.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the big things is there's a giant difference between the account and the
autopsy.
What,
what they said,
their description of the body and the wounds in Dallas versus their description
in the wounds in Bethesda,
Maryland,
two very different autopsies.
One of them that shows an entrance wound on the neck shows he got shot from the
front and an exit wound or an entrance wound on his neck and another one that
was changed to a tracheotomy scar.
So there's a discrepancy.
He grabs his neck.
It like he got hit,
he holds his neck maybe a second or two before his brain's blowout.
Right?
And when he's holding his neck like this on one autopsy,
on one account of the body,
that's an entrance wound from a bullet.
That's the Dallas one,
but on another one,
see if you see him when he's going around the corner.
He's already holding his neck.
Let's see how he's holding his neck like he,
he reached up and grabbed himself and he's looking down and right around he
passes the pole in his head blows off.
Watch this right here.
Boom.
I don't see anything.
I hang on a second.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
bitch,
get out the way.
This isn't super strong,
Sean.
The CEO's head disappears,
right?
They're like,
what is that?
It's like a,
it's just a flap of bone and meet it opened his head light out.
So watch,
look,
she ain't go in searching for a piece of hair and she's trying to get the fuck
off of that.
Well,
we don't know.
Limousine service guy right behind you,
bro.
That's a secret service guy was climbed up at the back of the car and he's
reaching for her to help her.
Oh my God,
what a horrible.
So,
but the problem was nobody had seen that until 10 years after the assassination.
So when they watch it,
they go,
oh my God,
his head goes back into the left.
That was like that Hicks joke that he kept talking about back into the lab,
back into the left.
I mean his,
he got shot.
It looked like he was getting shot from the front and it hit the right side of
his head and his head goes back into the left.
But there's also some spray that appears to be either going forward,
it could be an impact sprayer,
the bullet from the front,
or it could be that he got shot with two different bullets at the same time.
There's,
there's,
it's very possible that he,
he got hit from the front and the back.
It's basically very hard to tell what happened with one angle.
Right.
Well,
you know for sure he got shot in the head.
Yeah.
And you know that eat his head blew apart.
What's crazy to me at all after all these years,
we don't know for a fact.
No they can't.
There's no way they can notice.
Came out and toss it again.
Watch this again.
Now Watch.
Watch.
It's hard to tell if this is an impact spray or if it's an exit.
Where's his head at?
His head is right there.
It's like an impact right there.
Hey man,
but could be,
it could be an impact spray from the front meanwhile.
Okay.
It very well could be that.
It's an spray too,
but the thing is his head goes back into the left.
But here's the question.
Does it go back to the left from the momentum of getting hit in the head with a
bullet or is it a spasm from a dying body like your,
your body locks up and it just throws itself into a convulsion.
That's possible too.
I mean,
a lot of crazy shit happens when you get shot in the fucking head.
He was a real cocksman too.
I bet he was,
but I don't think that had anything go.
You don't think I'm just saying be Harvey Oswald acted alone.
I do not think Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone.
I do not.
I do not think that it's even,
uh,
even reasonable to assume that he act alone.
There's way,
way too many people that had invested in interest in killing him.
Like the Cubans,
like every,
there was a lot of people,
there was a lot of people that wanted him dead.
And it depends on what varying version of the story you're willing to buy into.
But what is possible,
and this is one thing that people don't want to consider,
they think either Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone or it's some wacky tinfoil hat
conspiracy.
I say neither.
I say it might be both.
I say Lee Harvey Oswald could have been in on it.
He seemed like a right,
like a gullible guy and a lot of ways,
right.
He'd been to Russia.
You've been rushed too,
but he lived in Russia,
was married to a Russian woman,
right.
Lee Harvey Oswald was most certainly at least in cahoots with the FBI.
He definitely,
yes.
He,
well,
he definitely did some things for other organizations.
Uh,
and brought over during the Cold War,
a Russian wife lived over in Russia and then got back in the United States and
brought over is Russia.
We did also go to Cuba,
right?
Didn't he spend time in Cuba?
Believe?
I believe he did.
I don't,
I don't remember that.
But I know for a fact he lived in Russia,
communist production,
but he was part of a,
a Cuban movement,
like a liberty for Cuba.
Cuba spent time in Kilby might have,
he didn't go to Cuba.
Okay,
well Jamie,
you'll find it.
But the,
but the bottom line is he easily could have been working for the government and
he easily could have been a part of the plan and he easily could have been a guy
that they fell.
Yeah,
they set him up because he still alive.
No,
we got shot by Jack Ruby like a couple of days after he shot Kennedy or
allegedly
tied evac and cancer in jail.
Not only that,
Jack Ruby was a mob guy that was deeply beholden to all these different groups.
And you know,
which is very weird,
right?
Why?
Why would Jack Ruby a mob guy kill meet Harvey Oswald in broad daylight while
he's being escorted?
Like what?
What would they,
they were like,
well,
he felt so bad for Jackie.
That doesn't make any sense.
The JFK story is vast.
It would take you fucking 25 hours.
People have written books on it.
I mean,
it's so deep.
Everybody wanted JFK dead.
The CII wanted them to get the Emmy season in Cuba and the Soviet Union,
so he wasn't killing oil.
Want to know that everybody wanted him dead.
So he's trying to change the world.
He visited embassies in Cuba and the Soviet Union to plot has escaped before
assassinating John F.
Kennedy.
I think he was in on it.
That's what I think.
For sure.
Yeah.
Lee Harvey Oswald didn't act alone,
but I do believe he was in on it and I bet he didn't pull the trigger.
I bet a bunch of other people pull the trigger and I bet he was the,
he was the guy they set up command.
Yeah,
because up there like Dallas Howard hunt is,
yes.
The Howard hunt was in the CIA.
He was part of a Watergate.
He's,
he's very big in the CIA on his deathbed.
He says that,
uh,
there was all the,
the assassins from operation 40 operations,
40 was a unit that,
that um,
they put together to assassinate Fidel Castro,
all these international killers.
It's just like,
uh,
like the murder incorporated operation 40 it,
yeah,
exactly.
All these,
these,
uh,
snipers and killers,
anti Castro,
Cubans,
you know,
there were exiled there.
They all got together.
They tried to kill Fidel Castro.
Bay of Pigs failed.
Um,
uh,
because JFK,
part of the reason was because,
uh,
JFK didn't,
um,
he,
uh,
he didn't want any air support.
He didn't want to be any part.
He didn't want any part of Bay of pigs.
So the CIA felt like they got abandoned by JFK.
JFK fires the head of the CIA.
So right there,
there was a big riff between the Cin,
JFK.
The mob hated JFK too,
because they were supposed to protect them.
Bob,
Robert Kennedy and JFK.
But because their dad was a mobster,
so they thought they were going to be protected.
So the mom spent all this money to get JFK n and then he's turning on him and,
and,
and Robert Kennedy,
his brother,
he's the attorney general.
He's going after the mob.
So they're like,
okay,
we got to stop these months.
So when you look,
when you look really,
really look into it,
a lot of people wanted him dead.
Big Oil wanted him dead.
They killed them in Texas.
Lyndon B Johnson,
the vice president was about to be indicted for two murders.
He had the,
you know how,
how,
uh,
he stopped that.
JFK got assassinated.
He becomes president.
He pardons himself.
It was a crazy time,
different place.
Not a lot on his death bed.
Said operation for the Bulimia,
depression 40 were all there.
They were all there to watch the big event.
They all collaborate.
He says it's on his deathbed and here's even,
he was there as a bomb.
He was one of the bumps.
We were all watching.
There's a photograph of him.
There's was a photograph of him from the arrest.
They arrested a bunch of Hobos.
I said getting off a plane,
rock killers.
They were all assassins.
They were and they've identified some of the guys who were on that,
on that train.
One of them was a fucking,
the the actor,
the fuck's his name.
Woody Harrelson.
Harrelson.
Where he house.
His Dad was the assassin.
Dad was an assassin,
like legitimate in a sense and crazy and e on his death bed.
You can watch this at the library on Youtube.
[inaudible]
hunt.
He said he was,
he was bench warming.
He was,
there was a lot just in case something went wrong.
There was a bunch of people there.
He was getting shot.
He was getting lit up from all sorts of the Hobos were undercover cops?
No,
no.
The whole boat or
at least one of the Hobos had been identified as a known as as done.
Not just the hour,
but there's other guys that have like,
people have broken down the photos of the Hobos and they said that,
that this guy is that guy.
This guy's an assassin.
Like what they weighed it,
it seems like they had done was they had planned to kill Kennedy and they
planned to do it in Dallas for some reason and they brought in a bunch of
different people to do it.
Now here's where it gets really squirrely.
When you find out how many people who are witnesses who testified that they were
there at the shooting wound up dying and really fucked up ways.
They wound up dying by murder.
They wound up dying and weird car accidents where they're fucking break lines
were cut.
There was a ton of them.
So many of them that they,
someone,
I think it might've been lifting as well.
David lifted the same guy who wrote best evidence.
They had some calculation on what the odds are of all these people meeting
violent demises inside of two years.
And it was crazy,
bro.
See if you could find that young.
Jamie got the plug from final p.
Um,
no.
How many people see if the,
the,
the amount of people who witnessed the Kennedy assassination,
who wound up dying under mysterious circumstances,
crazy shit.
Astronauts,
aliens to one.
It's like a millions to one.
Like if you look at how many people died and what are the odds of them all like
getting murdered or killed in suicide,
suicide.
We are weird suicides,
you know,
like hang themselves on a fucking coat rack.
Like weird shit.
Yeah,
Jay,
the JFK story is deep as fuck.
They killed that guy,
buddy.
Everybody collaborated.
They all agreed we need to get rid of this guy.
See,
I'm surprised more guys as they get older than them,
their deathbed.
Don't tell the truth.
Nobody cares.
Here's the thing.
By then there is also plenty of fake stories.
All they have to do,
look at it.
Here we go.
Here.
Look at this 101,000 trillion to one.
Some have claimed that a large number of witness and event of died mysterious
circumstances Sunday Times reported that the odds against these witnesses being
dead by February,
1967 or 100,000 trillion to one whoa
admitted he had made a careless journalistic mistake in his book,
a crossfire author Jim marrs provides a list of 103 people he claimed died in
mysterious circumstances between 63 and 76 in reality,
most of these people died of natural causes.
Some of these people did die in accidents.
Others were murdered or committed suicide.
However,
these people rarely had information that would have been important in helping
advance that.
That sounds like an editorialization.
I want to know who's writing.
I think about it.
If you're going to pull off an assassination and then you're all going to go as
a group,
let's kill everybody around them.
Doesn't matter.
That's hard to do.
That doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
I don't have to.
I'm looking at that.
Right.
What I'm saying is what that guy wrote is an editorialization like that might be
correct,
but it might be wrong too.
He's making an assumption and he's writing this gas based on that assumption.
Wow.
I mean,
I dunno how you'd like,
okay,
so you've got all those witnesses.
That's how fucking,
that's really hard.
Now you've got to organize all those murders.
Good luck.
All these different people that were witnesses.
Look at this.
Get,
make that a little larger,
Jamie.
So I could read this shit.
Look at this.
They all die pretty spaced out that a lot of times you're talking to these,
oh,
these are all Kennedy's that were whacked.
Yeah.
Well everybody hates the Kennedys,
man.
They were,
they started out kill him again.
I started out as drug runners.
They were running moonshine.
That's how they started.
That's where they made their money.
Joe Kennedy
and JFK and,
and,
and uh,
the rest of his sons,
they started trying to change the world for real.
And they're like,
what are you doing happening?
Everybody want to,
JFK died.
They knew.
They joked around about how they knew what they were trying to do is,
you know,
put their lives in jeopardy.
You know,
what's really interesting?
Robertson,
the way his son died on that plane.
You look into that.
Holy Shot.
That guy was coked up,
man.
He's coked up and he didn't know what he was doing.
He was driving into the fog.
You have to be really good.
You got to look into,
I did.
Did you really?
Yeah.
Do you think?
Did he died?
He died with cocaine in his system and he didn't know how to drive the plot of
shady shit to people.
People could fish body.
They found a plain,
they found his body when people had a rash over a hundred murder,
suicides and mysterious deaths.
The strange fate of those who saw Kennedy shot for sure live.
He saw it.
See,
I'd have to,
I'd have to read all these different,
you're organized is killed by a karate job.
What's coming out?
Sign out.
I'm a patsy.
I'm being set up pop,
pop,
and then Jack Ruby shoots him on TV and this is Jim Khan was killed by a karate
chop to the throat as the emergency shout there,
Jack Ruby killing.
That's what makes raises mind where I go.
Why would Jack Ruby killed so much
and then just keep his mouth shut and go to jail?
What the fuck is that about?
That?
That's the part that I think is really super expert on JFK.
You know more than I do,
but I spent a lot of time on JFK as well.
I just,
you just,
you know,
I just let you talk,
but I know a lot about that and there's so much,
there's people that these people that know way more than me,
only read a few people's books.
The guy that blows me away the most about JFK,
who knows that he studies all the players.
All the mob guys involved is a guy named ride Dawson.
He's fucking JFK encyclopedia.
Dude.
He knows.
It's so deep.
It's like game of Thrones times 10 yeah.
It's hard to tell who's right.
It isn't just JFK be Harvey Oswald and maybe a couple other assassins.
It's so goddamn deep.
Do you could spend a life,
a lifetime just studying and all the names and how they're all connected.
It's crazy.
It's super fast.
Okay.